so i uh wanted to talk to you a little
bit about
atherosclerosis and i have already
cheated a little bit and i started
drawing i wanted to make it a slightly
nicer drawing because i wanted to make
sure that the important things we can
actually see them and that it's pretty
clear so in the top left i have a small
vessel and i have the three layers and
in the middle is the lumen and on the
outside is the the outside so
this little white box i've drawn i've
tried to blow it up for you a little bit
here so again
over on this side we have the lumen
just to orient you again and this is the
outside of a blood vessel so we know
blood vessels have three layers and this
particular blood vessel is
actually let me label it is a middle or
large artery so i'm specifically talking
about large
and middle sized arteries here
and the reason that this makes a
difference
i'll point out
specifically again
but
there are these green little coils i've
drawn here like these little
green
squigglies
and this is a little protein called
elastin and i specifically want to talk
about these arteries because these large
and middle arteries that have
in them in the walls elastin
are very very susceptible to
atherosclerosis this process and so
i thought that
it makes sense to point it out just so
you know exactly which vessels are being
affected by this process
so let's go through and very quickly
refresh ourselves and talk about the
three layers
of the vessel we have the intima the
tunica intima and i'm just writing t for
tunica
and then the that's the innermost layer
the middle layer right here in red is
the tunica media
and i remember that because it's the
middle layer so media middle
and on the outside right here is the
tunica externa
externa kind of the external layer
and sometimes you'll see that as
adventitia another word for it so these
are the three layers we know this
and the way that atherosclerosis
happens now this is a process and it's
uh
it's a process that affects millions and
millions of people um
the way this happens is that it usually
affects these large vessels a large
middle arteries and actually these
vessels just to give you a little bit of
an orientation i'm talking about one
millimeter sized
vessels all the way to about 25
millimeters in diameter so
kind of uh kind of biggish vessels that
you could actually see with your naked
eye this could be like the artery that
maybe maybe the aorta the largest artery
it could be an artery that goes out to
my arm the brachial artery so any of
these large or middle size arteries
fit into this category and they're
affected by atherosclerosis and so the
first step in atherosclerosis let's just
jump into it
is that you have an irritant
some irritant and that could be
i'm not talking about
maybe someone's annoying little
uh brother or sister annoying neighbor
but some irritant like let's say you
have uh here i'll draw it in red a toxin
from cigarette smoke
so let's say you have some toxin that's
swimming through your blood vessels and
that could be an irritant
another irritant could be so i'll put
smoking up here for that another
irritant could be maybe having too much
lipids so maybe uh hyperlipidemia
hyperlipidemia and when i say lipid i
mean
specifically fats and cholesterol so you
could have little droplets that show
little yellow droplets because i think
of yellow as fat
of ldl this is a a protein
ldl stands for hdl write that out
low
density
that's what the l and the d are
low density lipoprotein so there's
basically something that carries fat and
cholesterol around your blood so you
could have
too much of it you could have too much
ldl
in your blood
in the in the blood vessels and the
arteries and that could be an irritant
or it could be maybe i'll use um
a dart maybe a white color here maybe it
could be high blood pressure
high blood pressure pushing out on these
vessels
could be an irritant so any of these
things could be an irritant
hyperlipidemia smoking or hypertension
or high blood pressure
could be an irritant and what is being
irritated what is the thing that is
being irritated so that's number two is
the layer of cells right here this inner
layer of cells in the tunica intima
and that layer of cells we know is the
endothelial
layer endothelial
cells so that's the layer that's being
offended somehow so it's being upset or
angry it's getting upset at these
irritants
so let me show some unhappy faces here
maybe some unhappy faces down here from
the ldl maybe some unhappiness from that
high blood pressure
and right behind it just uh to orient
you is the basement membrane
but really again it's the endothelial
cells that are being irritated
right so that would be step two
is endothelial
actually leaving the same color
endothelial
dysfunction they stop working the way
that they like to work
and i'll
uh try to be a little bit more specific
endothelial cells are basically a
barrier right they're they're
creating a barrier between what is
flowing through the blood and the wall
itself right they're the first thing
that molecules and cells in the blood
are going to see
and so if you have endothelial
dysfunction what you get is that this
barrier starts breaking down and so this
barrier
let me erase some of this stuff now just
to make some space we know that ldl is
low density lipoprotein i'll erase that
and i'll erase these white arrows for
the hypertension
and i'll even erase the cigarette smoke
the toxin and i'll leave the ldl for a
second you'll see why but basically let
me show you that these cells start
getting unhappy and they start breaking
down
and i guess i erased a lot of it but
i'll draw some of it back
and
what you get is
something like this you basically have
now
a breach
a breach so you have
these cells here
but now they're letting
stuff through and the stuff that gets
through primarily
and this is of importance to us
is the ldl so even if something else was
the irritant let's say cigarette smoke
was the major irritant here
and you get endothelial dysfunction from
that
the next step in atherosclerosis step
three is ldl
goes into i'll just write into
t or tunica intimate
this is kind of the next major step is
that ldl decides that it wants to go
inside it likes to be inside
of this layer and so you get ldl
hanging out over here i'll just write
ldl here
just so you know what we're talking
about
see all the these little molecules of
ldl which again uh
you know bring with them a lot of fat
and cholesterol
and they're all now in this tunica
intima layer so they're all within this
tunica into malaria let me make sure i
make that very clear
all within this layer of tunica intima
so they're not usually there and that's
step three
now step four really really interesting
this is where things get really kind of
wild
is you have
cells in your immune system
that are right here called macrophages
macrophages
and these macrophages
they have huge mouths and they are
actually macrophage really means big
eater so macrophage macro big and phage
meaning to eat macrophages
actually
swim through the blood and are
patrolling the blood almost like police
officers
and they sense that hey something is not
right with this wall there's ldl in
there and they go in pursuit they go
after that ldl and now they go into the
wall so now you've got ldl on the wall
you've got macrophages in the wall and
so i'm going to draw these macrophages
not to scale because again they're
they're bigger than this but they're now
in the wall they're hanging out in this
area
right
and they start devouring again they're
big eaters so they start devouring
gobbling up all that fat
so this is going to get a little bit
tricky but let me try to sketch it out
again up here for you they start
gobbling up fat
and they get loaded
with this little fat these little
particles of ldl so this is now ldl
that's inside of the macrophage right
and if you look through a microscope
what this might look like
is now you have to use your imagination
here but is sea foam so if you actually
go out to the sea
uh you know let's say you go to the
mediterranean sea and you look at sea
foam
that's actually what it would look like
potentially that's someone thought so
anyway and so basically they called
these cells these macrophages that have
gobbled up ldl and actually died so this
cell has now died i'll draw little x's
because it ate so much it died
these cells they call them foam cells
foam cells and i'll just uh write a
little arrow here
so you know which one i'm talking about
foam cells
so if you look in the tunica intima
again that's where all the action is
right this is this is the important part
here i'll i'll draw a box around it
that's kind of the center stage
the ldl the the macrophages that chased
it down and now the dead foam cells are
all sitting here
in this lake of fat so now we've got
macrophages as step four let me just
make sure i catch up with our picture
macrophages
and plus foam cells
foam cells
into
tunica intima right so now we're we're
all on the same page
and this
this
intima now really starts looking a lot
like this let me erase this uh clean
this up a little bit because it's
getting quite messy i think dude you'd
agree it needs a little cleaning up
let me erase all this stuff on the
outside we know that ldl was in the
blood but it went into the intima we
know that so
so now you have
basically
this ldl all these little molecules of
ldl start merging
into literally
a lake
think of like a lake
of fat and how disgusting a thought is
at right like a lake of lard
here
or fat
here because it's it's your fat or this
person's fat
and it's all
in this layer
called the tunica
intima in fact let me even draw another
dead
macrophage this is another foam cell
making a foam cell out of this it looks
like seafoam maybe
and so you have
here a lake of ldl
you have foam cells
and
it's all sitting in the tunica intima
and if you're actually two let's say
you're to fillet this cell open or this
uh blood vessel open let me try to show
what i mean if you're let's say you have
this blood vessel i'm drawing it very
simply now you know that there are three
layers not the one that i'm drawing
there but just imagine that you took a
knife and you sliced through it so now
you basically are looking at kind of
just the inside of it
right
just the inside of it what you would see
is basically just a giant streak
of fat
and this is kind of that lake that i
just showed you right um
now looking at it lengthwise so this
lake of fat
is
called a fatty streak so if you open up
a blood vessel
and look at it if this process has been
going on
you might start seeing fatty streaks
and so that's basically
the first half of atherosclerosis so
let's pick up there in the next video